- Come into my makeup first.
- (laughs) Do I look good?
Oh, this is gonna be used, isn't it?
(laughs)
What's up ladies and
gentlemen, boys and girls.
And welcome to the first episode
of the Trash Taste Podcast.
- How are you?
The official first episode
- The official first episode,
we've finally made it.
I'm your host for today Joey
and joining me every
week is Garnt and Connor.
- Hey guys.
- What's up.
- So yeah, is finally happening.
- It's finally happening.
Oh my God.
You do not know how long
we've been planning this
and how long we've
wanted this to have this.
- Like how long has it been?
I mean, we've been conceptualize
in this podcast for like what?
Over a year.
- Yeah
Yeah, t's been year, a year,
at least possibly years.
- Cause I mean, when we
decided we were gonna move
to Japan, I think the first thing
in our mind was we've
been gonna make a podcast.
- Yeah.
- But I think even before that,
the idea of just us
finally getting into a room
and just, you know, not
doing a one of collabo doing
like a continual collabo
has been, you know
in our minds for ages.
- Yeah I wanna say several years at least.
- Yeah.
- At least almost as known
as like along is half known,
(laughs)
You don't do really cool a podcast.
- I'm just left out here.
(laughing)
I was tacked on at the end, no.
- Let's talk about that,
like how we first met each other
because I think that's a good
introduction to this podcast
and how we've grown.
- Yes because you never know
there might be someone watching
who doesn't know like who is that guy?
Who is that guy?
Who's this guy?
- Exactly, right.
- Hi, I'm Connor, hi.
(laughing)
And another channel.
- Hopefully surprised
if there is someone watching first episode
who doesn't know like who's three of us?
- Yeah exactly.
- Maybe.
- Or maybe they've seen us.
- You see if you did
then can you please
tell us in the comments
well how you found this video.
(Garnt laughs)
- Because we're just so famous
then you've not this
for not knowing who we are there.
- I swear.
So, yeah let's actually, you know what,
before we talk about that,
we should probably talk
about what this podcast is.
- Oh yeah.
- That's true.
- We just like rushing into things
'cause there's so, we're so like excited.
- I'm finally (mumbles)
- Who's so excited to get
this thing off the ground?
So basically Trash Taste as
the name implies is a podcast
where we us three and maybe sometimes
even a guest you never
know, comes onto the show
and we basically talk
about our Trash Taste.
Whether it comes to Anime,
Manga, and Otaku culture
in general, or you never know,
we might talk about
whatever the fuck we want.
Who knows?
- Yeah, 'cause if, if you didn't know,
we are all like Anime YouTubers.
- So
- No why?
(laughing)
- Bro
- This guy called the Anime Man.
(laughing)
- I really felt myself
for that one definitely.
- This guy called CDAWG VA which
- My God
- Garnt that too.
- What is VAsten for?
- Virginia is all the comments
(laughing)
- He's from Virginia.
- It's okay, 'cause the amount of years
that I still get comments,
which is like, they call me Gigg UK
and not Gigguk.
(laughing)
- How do you do that?
- I mean listen, people
might call you Gigg UK
but I still know you as
the animation (mumbles)
(laughing)
But AC in the thumbnails,
in the old thumbnails.
That's how I knew I was
watching an Anime Zone.
- Actually I'm not curious.
How long have you been watching my videos?
Because this ties into
how we first met as well.
- I've known you I mean,
I obviously, as I said,
I've known you since the Anime Zone.
- That's like...
- Which is like a long time.
But I think I, like, I watched
you probably not knowing
that you will like this
like YouTube personality.
- Yeah same.
- Because like, I was
in like a weird state.
I don't think I discovered
YouTubers until maybe about 2011.
- Yeah.
- Maybe because they'd been around
for a long time since then.
- Yeah.
- And obviously you've
been around since then.
But I never like went onto YouTube being
like I'm gonna go check
out my favorite YouTube.
(Garnt laughs)
I kind of just use YouTube
up until around 2011.
I think I just use YouTube
as to like either watch music
or listen to music videos or just to like,
Oh this is an interesting looking video.
And I think a couple of your videos will
like the interesting looking ones.
I think I remember actually
the first video I ever watched
from you surprisingly was not EvAbridged.
- Oh share okay.
- I watched EvAbridged
when I like the idea
of an came around.
- And an bridged series.
- Yeah and I was like, oh a bridging.
That sounds fun, but tedious as fun.
(laughs)
But no, I think the first
video I watched from you was,
Oh God, I probably wanna say it's
the Summer Wars Review you did?
Oh my God.
- Like the one you did like 2000
- What's going (mumbles)
what's the fuck man?
- I never even saw your EvAbridged.
I just, cause I didn't watch Davis.
There was a lot of watched your bri...
I don't know what is sounds.
like, I wanna watch that
So I think I watched some of your stuff.
I just knew you always the British one.
- Yeah.
(laughing)
- The British.
That's my brand name.
- 'Cause there was like,
it was like Tristin
and then you in my mind.
I think that was it to a lot of people
when I was, when I got into it like 2013,
I start watching YouTube a
lot, especially anime stuff.
- Right.
- Yeah, but so how long have
you been doing YouTube for?
- I've been doing it since 2007.
(laughs)
- He's like an actual OG.
- I'll have to like Trace
Back, but I'm thinking I'm
like the fifth ever Anime YouTuber
of all the time might be
like four, four fifth.
But I've been there since the beginning.
I can recite the entire
history of Anime YouTube.
- Which we're definitely
gonna do with like a future
- Not for this episode,
'cause there's a lot to say,
but for now I remember the first,
I can't remember the exact first
video I saw from you, Joey.
But I remember your videos
just getting recommended
to be constantly.
And I'm just like my first thought was
how was no one taking the
handle, the anime (mumbles)
(laughing)
I've been on usual for
so many fucking years
and just now someone
it's called the Anime.
There's no fun.
- No but the thing is,
someone did take the hand land
because that's why like on
like even my YouTube URL
and like my Twitter and everything,
it's the Anime Man but it's I it's a one.
Because somebody over a
Facebook, Twitter, Instagram,
like YouTube someone took the Anime Man.
He was like this guy who
never uploaded any videos.
(Garnt laughs)
And he's been around since like 2007.
Yeah it's always just like,
"men you are such a son of a bitch."
So I was like, well, what am I gonna do?
All right fuck (mumbles) to one.
Somehow that caught on and
I don't know how the fuck
but yeah.
I mean I've regret that name.
Let's be honest.
(laughing)
- I mean, it works for as you ever.
Because the reason I was
called the Anime Zone,
is because,
- You're an Anime.
- Yeah, yeah because back
- He will sing the song.
- But that back in the day
when you could just type an Anime
and it was just all my videos.
I'm like, man, I've won this game
I've playing the game correctly.
- And then I came along,
I was like, hold my beat.
(laughing)
- Exactly.
- You're in the zone, I'm the man.
- But I remember the
first time I have was,
I mean I don't think I ever
saw one of your videos.
The first time I heard about
you Conner was actually
when you "auditioned" for
one of my Abridged series.
- So really?
- Yeah, yeah is yes so I
haven't told this story
to Joey yet.
So I did a casting call for one of the
in minutes videos, right.
And I told people to send
in their some of the videos
- I'm trying to remember what this was now
because I remember.
- It's going all the way back.
And so I asked people to
send in their demo reel
and most people send in their demo reel
and this guy, this fuck doesn't
even send in a demo reel.
He just sends in a YouTube video
of him doing League of
Legends character impressions
(laughing)
- So why you should also
never do that yourself.
- Yeah, yeah don't, don't do that.
- When someone asked for
demos, send a demo reel,
you don't know I think at the time,
I didn't have a character demo.
- Do I still don't have
a character demo reel
because I never needed it.
Okay, his things were a
lot of character demos
on Twitter, you'll hear them.
They've really, really bad.
- Yeah.
- And the thing is when
you're making it yourself,
you don't have anyone to say like,
"hey you displease kind of sucks."
(laughs)
So like every time I've
made a professional demo,
I've had like a director
who's at hand shows
in every scene and told me what to do.
And then it sounds good
because someone who can
hear your voice and be like,
how do this and that.
Back then, I didn't know that.
And this is before I started doing
a lot of professional stuff and that.
- Yeah.
- That's a great way to introduce someone.
This is why,
this is also another thing
you shouldn't send a demo
to someone if it's garbage
'cause you guy, like this
guy still remembers that shit
- I even remember because
he was the only person
who didn't send a demo reel
but just sent a YouTube video
of him doing impressions.
Never send like if there is,
like a checklist of things
not to send for a demo,
do not send character impression.
- That's such a big, that's
such a big dick move.
(laughing)
It's like, I don't even
need cast demo reels.
My impressions are good enough.
(laughs)
- I'm sorry about that.-
- So, I mean, would you remember
which characters you did?
- I think so.
I think there were like,
I was just to bunch them manly
guys from League Legends.
It's just anyone with a low voice.
(mumbling)
(laughing)
I did long still (mumbles)
- It's like, its been awesome
seeing you how far you've come
from sending in a character
impression reel to be like.
- That was like, I
thought it must have been
just like a year or two
after I started as well.
When I still like, you think
that you figure stuff out
after a year but like you
realize when you look back
like you're still, you
just didn't know share
- Because what year did you start?
- YouTube?
YouTube I started 2015,
- 2015.
- 2015, I started voice acting
really in like 2013, like 2014.
So that gave me a big like advantage.
I went into it with like
a great mind microphone.
- Yeah.
- Which a lot of,
- 'Cause that voice acting.
- Yeah, and I mean, funny
enough how I met you
actually have the email sent to me.
- Weuh, weuh, weuh you have an email?
- I have the email.
- Before we started recording this one,
we're going to talk about
like how we all met one another.
This guy was like,
I don't think Joey remembers
the first time we met.
I think I do though.
- Okay, (mumbles) read the email that I.
Okay this is what I had.
- Why you you sent it to me, right?
- Yeah, yeah so this was about like,
how I must've been like four
months into me doing YouTube.
And I think I had like maybe 30, 40K subs.
Yeah, I think Joey, I think
he had like 900K at this time?
- Probably.
- He was something like,
you had a lot.
And like way more than I had.
And so I sent you an
email saying (mumbles)
like formal.
(laughing)
Hello there, my name is
Connor or CDawgVA on YouTube.
(Garnt laughs)
Why this is making any
sense grammatically?
(laughing)
(mumbles) I wish is commas.
"Hello there.
My name is Connor or CDawgVA
on YouTube channel here",
and then.
- Channel here
(laughing)
- Okay, here's where it starts
to get real crunch again.
"I've been working on a Levi
versus Sebastian Rap Battle."
- Oh my God!
(laughing loudly)
- Okay wait, I'll finish
it then I'll explain it.
"And it is about 90% complete.
I noticed you recently did a Rap Battle
and it was well done."
Wow, I couldn't have
kissed your ass more here.
(laughing)
"It's more of an insulting
each other a character rap.
I have the voice of Sebastian
Michaelis, English Dub
down to a tee."
Wow, it's really
- Wow, wow.
- "And I was wondering
if you'd like to be Levi
If you wish to talk to me more about it
and the logistics feel free
to contact me on Skype."
(laughing)
- Really Jesus.
- I wanted the sound professional was fun
or just reply to this email.
Any responses, appreciate it.
Kindly, Regards CDawgVA
of any used my real name
CDawgVA.
And then Joey replied saying.
"Hi there!
Sure, sounds like fun."
Smiley face.
"I added you on Skype
we can talk about it."
I remember the first thing
Joey sent me was like,
"your voice is cool is fun."
- Yeah and I was like, I
still think that it is.
- Yeah, so that's how like
and to this day I
thought that was so cool.
You actually replied
'cause I'm not gonna lie.
I'm kind of mean when
I see a video normally
when it's like collabo,
it's normally like.
- Its normally like.
- Yeah (laughing)
- Normally like I don't
know what I wanna do yet
but I wanna a collabo.
- Right.
- And it's a good, you don't
know what you wanna do yet.
You're pitching the
(mumbles) what the fuck?
So that's how I met you.
- Yeah I fucking remember that too,
because yeah, the the rap
battle I did was so bad.
Don't watch it.
♪ I could've spend more time ♪
♪ pwning royals at chess ♪
♪ but looks like I gotta prove to you ♪
♪ that I'm the best. ♪
♪ You wanna fight, little emo? ♪
♪ Well, be my guest! ♪
♪ I fought till the end ♪
♪ until I got a knife in my chest. ♪
- It was pretty bad.
- It was pretty fucking
battle at the time,
it was the first time I
ever used the green screen.
It might be (cheering)
even like because I was
in like my tiny bedroom
in Australia.
There was no place to like
prop up the green screen.
So what I had to do, it's so ghetto.
What I had to do was I had
to get the green screen
and literally like tape it to the ceiling
and I've done exactly the same thing.
Just like let it down and
just stand in front of it.
And like, I had no lights.
You could see my shadow fucking flickering
in and out the whole video.
I obviously couldn't rap at the time.
I'm a little bit better now,
but yeah it was, what was it?
It was a light no it was L from Death Note
versus Lelouch from Code Geass.
- I remember.
- And I played Lelouche
and another friend of mine played L.
- Yeah.
- And I think that video has
like half a million views.
I don't know how?
- Yeah
- I mean this is back when it was
like Epic Rap Battles of History.
- Yeah we basically
wanted to do an history
but with no cost plays
(laughs)
- It's a just.
- Rapping in front of a green screen.
(laughing loudly)
- Checks out that's like 2015 YouTube.
- But basically like that
kind of somehow popped off
for my channel and then yeah.
And then you.
- 'Cause I actually was writing that
with Gray Fox at the time.
- Yeah.
- Amazing guy.
And I thought like we had like a burger.
We had like so many like
Grey Fox had made the tracks
for many beats and they were like amazing.
- Man sending emails.
That's such a boom away
to slide into something.
(laughs)
- Not to mention, we
added each other on Skype.
(laughing)
The back, the good old days of Skype.
- And then I think like your
Skype account got hacked
or something like a sort.
- Yeah it got hacked twice
- That I know how I met
you, but it was weird
'cause I think Sydney.
I saw Sydney was following me.
- Yeah Sydsnap my fiance.
- Yeah and I think I followed her back
so I knew of Sydney and then Sydney DM me.
She'll say that she
didn't Sydney DM first.
(laughing)
And she was like, you're going to MCM
which is a convention in London
And I was like yeah okay.
And then Sydney was like,
"come, come to this meetup,
you can meet me in Garnt."
I didn't get to meet
Garnt he was too busy.
(laughing loudly)
So I turned up like an idiot like,
I'm like sea dog and stuff.
(mumbles)
(laughs loudly)
At the time I had like 200 K subscribers.
So it was like a substantial
amount for that time period.
- He was funny because you had a audience
that was vastly different from
every other Anime YouTuber.
- I mean still like that to this.
- [Both] Yeah, yeah.
- That's true.
It's gone like a lot less so at the time
and around 2000, the peak of it at 2014,
I had a 93% female audience.
- Which is unheard of.
- I think his nickname when
first met him was the 93%.
(laughing loudly)
We would just like how's the 90% doing?
- Okay I got bullied for it.
(laughing)
- I really wanna start
calling you (mumbles)
(laughing)
- It's like 55, 60% now.
It's leveled up.
- It's like you are going to enjoy.
(laughing)
Who's crazy though.
And that's like a whole
YouTube is in Anime.
All dudes there was like one
or two girls but just all dude.
So every time I turned up to
like an Anime YouTuber meetup,
everyone's like, "fuck
who the is this guy?"
How's he got 200K, how
does, how did he get that?
How would no one of us know who he is?
- Why this guy from Virginia?
(laughing)
What the fuck.
- Yeah, so I mean that time had gone.
And then we went from there.
- Yeah can I tell the story about
how the first time we met?
- Sure?
- Yeah, 'cause.
- I don't know where you're
gonna start this case.
- Okay so the first time we met in person,
so it was like a 2000 and is it 17
- [Both] or 16 or 17?
- I think so, I knew Joey.
I didn't know that he knew who I was.
- Right, and vice versa.
I knew Garnt, but I
didn't know if he knew me.
- Yeah, so this was back when I had, like,
if you didn't know,
I took a hiatus on YouTube
for like two years because
like got a real time,
a real job and everything like that.
And in that time I had gone from being
like one of the most
popular Anime YouTubers
to just, you know someone
who had taken a hiatus.
And in that time Joey had like exploded
like you've reached numbers
that's back in my time,
I didn't know was even fucking possible.
Like you were like close to a million,
you were like be like
(mumbles) at the time.
So the first time,
so the first time I saw Joey,
we were like in Little Tokyo or something?
- Yeah I remember
exactly where it was too.
It was that part in like the
back half of Little Tokyo.
Wrack it's like underneath a building
and you go into where there,
it's like a figuring shop there in.
And you were walking with Jeff, right?
- Yeah, yeah that's what a Jeff.
'Cause I think Jeff said hello to Misty
'cause they were both tall motherfucking
(laughing)
So he was just like standing
next to two fucking skyscrapers
while we're just hanging out.
And I remember looking at
you and you looked at me
and we didn't say shit to each other.
And I thought this, I
thought this motherfucking
must hate me.
This, motherfucker hates me.
- And at the same time I like gone,
like looked at each other in the eyes
and in my head I was like,
this guy definitely hates me.
(laughing loudly)
This guy hates my guts.
- So I'm just like man, Joey
is such an arrogant piece
of shit man.
(laughing)
Like I can't believe this guy.
- I remember we shook hands.
We were like, "hi I'm Joey, nice to me."
And you're like, "hi, I'm
Garnt, nice to meet you."
And that was it.
- And that was it, that's was the same.
- It was so awkward.
- Had never heard this story
- Well because the only people
who were there was Misty,
Jeff and Arche.
Just thinking, us too.
So it was like very small.
And then what?
Like, fast-forward like what?
Who he is?
- I think it was just,
I think it was next year,
it might've been even less than that.
When I came to a trip,
went onto a trip to Japan
or something and then.
- You randomly DMed me
- Yeah, yeah, yeah I was like,
for some reason he follows me.
So maybe he doesn't hate me.
- May be he is cool.
So yeah, we we DMed each other
and then we met in Japan
and then we just like instantly just
like fucking great friends, you know?
- Yeah and from that point.
We went to in his no
we met up in our Cobre.
- And we like hang out a little bit
and then we went to in Izakaya in Ueno
- Yeah, yeah.
- Till like two in the morning
or something like something
ridiculous like that.
We missed the last train.
- And then we were like.
- It sounds like a bromance.
(laughing)
- No.
- We missed the last train.
We had so much fun together.
(laughing)
- 'Cause we had the moment when we just,
were singing in there Izakaya
and I was like, I thought you hated me.
- And I was like, how
don't you hate on me.
(laughing)
So we don't hate each other.
- And then after that we
had like a Karaoke Night
where we...
- Yeah. I think it was
like a few days later.
- Yeah and I think that's when the seeds
of the podcast was so in my think.
because we were up to,
we missed the last train
and we were just with Karaoke
with each other and Sydney.
And there was like two other people.
- Yeah.
- And then everyone else had fallen asleep
but it was just us two and one other guy.
It was it like?
It was like 5:00 AM.
- I remember who the other guy was?
I don't remember either.
- Four guy.
- It wasn't like a
friend of Garnt or mine.
It was just a dude.
- He didn't know who we were.
Like, he didn't know that we were
like Anime YouTubers or anything.
So we were up at 5:00 AM, drunk shits.
And then me and Joey just
start hosting this panel
for this one guy all right.
- We each had like a
Karaoke microphone each
like echo you.
And we were just like,
welcome to the panel.
And there's this one dude across the table
be like (cheers).
- 'Cause yeah, he didn't know who we were
but we still would just hosted
this Anime panel for him.
I don't know if...
I didn't even know him,
if he watched anime or not
but I'm like Joey, what's your opinion
on Bucky Mourner Gutter,
who is the best skill?
- That's when all for like an hour
- Yeah and this went on for like an hour
then after that, we were like,
we need to host a panel together.
And we managed to do that last year at AX
- Which was awesome.
- That was amazing.
- Yes.
- Yeah like two, three years in the making
and in between that, we were like,
surely we gonna make a
podcast all the time then.
- And here we are after fucking what?
Three or four years.
- Yeah.
- From like first conception.
And like, even like planning
this whole podcast out
as well like took a very, very long time.
- Because this is
actually a studio for it.
- Yes so we had to
like, get our own studio
as you can see, we're still working on it,
still working on it,
but give us some time,
stick around for that.
- It's like getting a studio in Japan
- Oh my God.
- In Tokyo my God don't
even get me started
on how hard that was like.
- I'm sure we can talk about
in future our experiences
with just renting stuff in Japan, my God.
But yeah now you know, what's
funny when you guys are
like you said, he like just clicked
like that after you guys
start talking it's so like,
I think that happens easily
when you're both like around
the same, like sub thing.
Cause there's no question
if you're trying to leach off each other.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I remember like
when I first started
and when I was trying like,
when we were like first like hanging out,
I always felt like, man they wonder if I'm
just like a leach or something.
Cause like I had like 150, 200
and they had like million plus right.
So you just get this thing in your head.
You're like, man, am I like leaching?
Do they think that?
But then like when you get,
like I think now I don't give a shit
because like I.
- I mean like concerning you and I,
when we popped off very naturally
because spoiler we never ended up doing
that fucking Rap Battle.
- Yeah.
- And that just like disappeared
because I think the first time
I like publicly did something
with you was on your stream.
- Yeah, yeah you did.
- And we played BROFORCE together
for like three hours.
- Yeah, it's still up on, on YouTube.
- Really?
- Yeah and then I think we just,
I played a lot of games
on your stream with you.
And then I think we just hang out at AX
and you just went and then obviously.
- 'Cause we tie like Metal Slug (mumbles)
- Metal Slugs is like my favorite games.
And then I think we
just did British things
and met up and got, yeah.
(mumbling)
I feel like it's so easy to
befriend other British people
'cause it's just like, we
just get it I don't know.
- Not, like going off to what you said
about feeling like your
leaching from someone.
- Yeah.
- It's weird right because you can,
as someone who's been in the position of,
you know, not being a smaller YouTuber
and in a larger YouTuber,
it's you can kind of get a sense just
from meeting a plus in this house.
Actually if you meet
them in real life, right?
Online it's so fucking difficult
to gauge what a character
what someone's character is actually like.
And you know, if they're
trying to, you know,
leach off you get clout or whatever,
but especially at a event like AX.
(laughs)
- Where the real person comes out.
- Yeah, you can definitely
get a better judge
of character at a convention
or meeting someone
in real life, like a big event, like AX.
- I think there's also a lot with that.
Is that when you're at AX,
I think some people think, okay
I've only got five minutes with this guy
and I've got to like befriend him.
- Yeah.
- So they, I think they, like
sometimes they go overboard
with like trying to impress
you where it's like,
what the fuck is this guy?
- I mean, one thing I've noticed
with when it comes to like,
'cause I've been to so many conventions
where like people have come up to me
just for that like five
minutes that they have time
with somebody that's an like just,
I don't wanna say kiss us
but you know, when
someone's trying to kiss us
or like, but like the thing is that like,
at least earlier on when I
would meet people like that
and they're trying to be nice
to me during those five minutes.
I didn't know if they were
Just trying to kiss my ass
or if they would genuinely nice people.
- Yeah.
- But the one way I
found it is if they can,
I guess like maybe try and
maintain that friendship
with you and try and stay contact with you
after that event.
Then I think there like
genuinely nice people.
- Yeah, because I don't
wanna make it sound
like we're all fucking assholes.
(laughing)
Talking with, hearing about how you
just messaged Conner back
from just that one email,
I also remember the point when
I would just try to like talk
to everyone and collaborate with everyone.
But then you get to a
point when you see that 90%
of these emails, 90%
of these people talking
to you don't actually mean what
they mean or they're looking
for something and you get a sense.
You get a sense for that as time goes by.
So it's.
- I feel like you can just
glance at an email now
and you know what they're up to.
What I'm trying to get.
- Usually if it starts
with I'm 13 years old,
(laughing)
then that's something (mumbles) to delete.
- Actually here's a question for you.
What's the way I know
you've got some stories
of this Conner.
- I don't.
- What are some of like
the weirdest fun emails,
you've ever received?
(laughing)
- It's like, I get them every week.
I like to say every week, but it's like,
I've gotten some where it's just like,
I genuinely think like I'm
actually scared to open it.
Even though there's like
no attachments, no links
or anything, but even a subject title.
It's literally just, I open
it and it says, "you're cool."
(laughing)
Opening an email like
that at like midnight is
like the scariest ever,
because I'm just like did
my computer just get act.
I don't know if this is like an elaborate
like chores or if it's
just like a 10-year old
who's learning to use email
for the first time like.
I'm like thanks but who are you?
- When they just send a link, that's cool.
It's sounds like (laughs)
- No that's all it looks like
- Men I don't know, I've
got so many stories,
I guess of emails because
I guess it's my fault
because I kind of encouraged
that a little bit.
- Yeah.
- I've made multiple videos
where I've got content
from my email sometimes it's good
but then also I think now
since I've joined an agency,
I feel bad for the agency
where they sometimes
see the shit I get said.
(laughing)
Luckily I normally like delete the ones
that I know are like
they're just trolling.
The full by agency can see it.
'Cause I don't want some
Japanese worker opening my email
and it being like, "hey, I
think you're dummy thick."
And I'm 13 by the way.
(laughing)
You get stuff where they'll say like,
they wanna date you
and they'll put the 13.
And like, it's just like,
this is Chris Hansen is
Chris Hansen emailing me.
I think I've spoken about
this in a video once.
But there was someone who emailed me
and I still remember this.
'cause like I had an
interview, I replied to it
and it was this interaction
where they sent me a script
of phone sex that we'll gonna have.
- What?
- So it looked like it was like,
- I actually still have the script.
I'm not gonna read it out
because there's more to the story.
There's the reason why
I decided not make it
into a video.
But it was like a script and (laughs)
first it was one script was me and her
and there was also a music setlist
that she'd chosen.
So that was when the music was playing.
(laughing)
- You in the end by Lincoln Park
- It was like pour some sugar on me,
you know like the cheesiest song.
And so I thought in my head,
'cause back then I read
all of them in depth
and I thought wow, this is the video idea.
If I can like, keep this going.
- And there's also another
script where is me having gay sex
with Sebastian Michael's.
- Of course
- Of course.
- I mean, that would be expected.
- It's funny that's like
not the weirdest story.
- I'm surprised you didn't make a video.
- Wow, okay this why and I feel bad.
I hope this person isn't watching.
So I interacted with them
a bit and they were like
obviously I knew they were
gonna be strange right.
Because you sent an email like that.
And I started interacting
with them more and more.
And then they started sending
me way too much information
about themselves.
There's also another guy
who sent me his birth
certificate by the way.
That's all (mumbles)
- Don't do that.
Don't do that.
- That's dangerous.
- I didn't ask for his opening email,
was his my birth certificate,
driving license, address.
And I was like, what?
(laughing)
I also mentioned this.
I don't know which video I said,
I mentioned all this, but yeah.
So I replied to this
person, I kept replying
with them 'cause they kept
replying with really funny stuff.
And I was like, Oh my God,
I can get an amazing video out of this.
And then, with the one thing they said
which made me think, okay
now I just have to like completely
scrapple this is the day
and they said like, "oh
here are my hobbies,
hobbies, blah, blah, blah
by the way, I'm in the Special
Olympics Team for the USA."
And I was like, "oh my God, what?
No, no, no, no, like why you
shouldn't be sending this?
And then I explained to
them, you know, I was like
hey, maybe you shouldn't
send this email to me.
And you know, I don't think
this is appropriate way.
And I'm very sorry for like messing
with your time and stuff.
And I just, it was a whole
thing where I was like,
oh my God, I'm in a asshole.
And Jesus Christ like.
But yeah there's so
many emails I've gotten
I mean, I made a whole video where, I went
on a date with someone in it was a date.
- Yeah.
- From an email.
- That was scary watching that video.
- You were like Connor's gotta get cancer.
(laughing)
- This kid's gonna get stabbed.
- I remember you pitching
that video idea to me
and I'm just like,
Conner I don't know if
that's the best idea,
but I mean it turned out a good video.
- Yeah I pitched it like 10 of our friends
and everyone's like, "wow, wow, wow
Conner, Conner no, don't
do that, don't do that."
- Whenever I ask my friend
was like genuinely worried
for you is like, I really don't think.
I think Connor's going to die.
- I think if you watch the video,
they felt more concerned for the girl
because we turned up with light,
me, Evan Budan and another guy.
I just won't go.
Yeah I just said one go alone right.
So, like you know, but it
also awesome in the end,
it was all awesome.
- She really nice about the video.
She actually liked the video.
So that was good.
- She just walked into a casting couch.
I guess like I don't get so about that.
Exactly, I can't talk
I actually don't get
that many weird emails
or weird fan mails.
I don't know, I guess, it's
'cause I mostly talk about anime
and it's less about my
own personality, I guess.
I don't know, I guess like
one weird email I got recently
which wasn't even an emailed to me, right.
So someone used my email
and pretended to be me
and emailed STUDIO WIT.
(laughing)
Okay, I got the email here actually.
They emailed STUDIO WIT
pretending to be me.
'Cause they use my email
and I got a notification
from the official studio
with like, you know,
like the automatic notification that says,
"hey you've submitted this email to us."
Okay so the email reads.
"Hello, I am anime reviewer Gigguk,
(Conner laughs)
I will make a request of you.
Many people once Eren and
Mikasa to have a relationship.
(laughing)
Eren X Mikasa.
I think if this happens,
many people will enjoy the anime more."
(laughing)
- And this has to be a troll.
- "I would be pleased with
the development of events
in this direction that it was.
(laughing)
I hope you will evaluates my proposal.
I wish you good day."
- Man.
- "I wish you good day."
(laughs)
- This sounds like the
email I sent contactly
for more so we can
figure out the logistics.
- We can figure the
logistics of Eren X Mikasa.
(laughing)
- Oh my God!
- You know, let's just
completely bypass this SAR
might just go straight to I, feel like.
- They have that the final say.
- We're doing this.
- I like how they just emailed STUDIO WIT
who has no creative control
over how Attack on Titan
is gonna end anyway.
- I really want, I really wish that
like STUDIO WIT took that email seriously
and like actually hooked up.
Like you say, "I'm a being late."
So this popular animated review was
(laughing)
- You know Gigguk of right?
- "You know Gigg of right, Gigg UK?"
If she wants Eren and Mikasa together?.
Do you think that's possible?
- Can you make this a thing?
- Can you please make this a thing.
- Hey, season four, Attack on Titan.
I'm ready, I'm ready.
- Hey, you never know like
none of us have caught up
on the manga, right?
- Yeah
- No, no, it might, it might happen.
- I feel like, it's a crime to.
- And if it does happen, we
can thank a certain email.
(laughing)
- Eren X Mikasa is a thing I know.
I know, who calls this.
(laughing)
- Jesus Christ.
- I think, I mean
To break out this.
This is been a long time coming.
Welcome to Trash Taste Podcast.
- If you want to know
drinking is going to be
of quite frequent occurrence on this show.
So get used to it.
- Yeah, so that was
I didn't imagine our intro
is gonna be that long though.
In my head I was like.
(cheering)
- Finally.
I think , would you guys all say
that an Attack on Titan season four
as your most anticipated.
- Absolutely.
So how do you even match
that hype of this point?
- Wait it's takes?
- It's it was meant to
be airing this fall.
I think
- No this Summer I believe
- No it was definitely, it was fall.
- Really?
- Yeah
- You've (mumbles)
(laughing)
- So I should have gone up
against the guy emails to deal
with.
(laughing)
- Personal contact that way.
- But yeah, I think it's, I'm pretty sure
it's Eren it was scheduled to a next fall.
And I've heard from,
because I made a video
about the first three seasons of (mumbles)
and I've heard from pretty much everyone
who's read the manga
that season four is going
to be the best season.
- No, I have also heard.
- I mean even if it was just mediocre,
I feel like it would still
like, just think it's amazing.
'Cause I did journey to
get there has been sure
and this last part was, oh my God.
- Every (mumbles) was as hey
- My God.
Like, it's so rare that
you get to see a series
just improve over time every season.
Because I remember
when Attack on Titan season
one was airing right?
And I was, it was great.
It was great.
But I felt like it was very forgettable
in the sense of,
well, I remember when season two ads,
I didn't remember anything
that happened in season one.
- You don't I remember
specifically in your video
of the like seasonal review, you said,
remember the Attack on Titan
and then you just play cricket noises.
(laughing)
And I remember being like well,
I'm watching Attack on Titan season two.
It's good and I think.
- No I do agree like season two,
because season one when I watched it,
I was like, okay this.
(mumbling)
And then season two came around
and actually dropped it.
- No one cared drinks.
- Because I think what it was, was that
because season one was, you
know, all about like the action
and just like building the world
and then season two was a lot of politics
and a lot of talking.
- Yes season two just took the pace
'cause season one was like
a fucking roller coaster.
You were going up and
down every few episodes.
It's like, you didn't know
what was gonna happen.
But to me it felt a bit empty
and season two felt much slower paced.
There was more of like a slow burn
when they focus more on the characters.
But I actually got really
drawn into the world
way more into season two.
But by the time season two ended,
I was like, okay I'm now way more invested
but nothing really big has happened.
- 'Cause it was 12 episodes.
- Yeah, yeah it was just 12 episodes.
- I think everyone was like,
what the fuck we've waited four years
or something for 12 episodes.
- Because they rushed it out.
- Yeah.
But you expected it.
I mean, definitely I think in season three
when that scene with Levi came out,
as I think when it just exploded
because everyone saw that GIF on Twitter,
it was like I got a fucking catch up
like saying like just
thinking about that scene,
like gives me goosebumps.
It's so good.
- It's so good
- Because I remember season three,
part one I enjoyed so fucking much.
'Cause I didn't realize I could care
about the politics that
much in the Attack on Titan
'cause I remember by the
time season three started,
I was enjoying Attack on Titan
for completely different
reasons than season one.
You know what I mean?
I can say the same thing
about every season.
So I've heard season four is going
to be completely different,
completely different to
what's previously been.
- 'Cause I mean like, I
don't remember when it was,
but me and Aki went to the
Attack on Titan exhibit
that they did in Roppongi.
And basically it was really tough
because what they did was essentially,
they really catered to the Manga Reader,
unfortunately and I am
not the Manga Reader.
So in like the late of
rooms of this exhibit,
they basically like on all the walls,
they would have like the
original Ganga of the Manga right
in these frames, which is fucking cool.
But then as he got
further down the exhibit,
they would start showing stuff
that hadn't been adapted yet.
So I was like, all right
(laughing)
Cover my eyes.
But obviously there was just some stuff
that I couldn't really avoid seeing.
And the tiny little bit that
I did say out of context,
I was like,
- What the fuck?
- Wow, there is no fucking
way that's happening.
And then to top it off,
there was this room.
This was like a really
experimental move on them,
their part but there was this room
that you had to go into
and it was completely pitch-black room.
And there's just audio
playing on the speakers
in this pitch-black room.
And what that audio is,
it's audio of what he say I'm
envisions the final chapter
of the Attack on Titan time to be.
- That's so this you should handled.
- There's no visuals, there's no visuals.
It's just audio.
And it's what he envisions.
It will sound like adapted.
The only thing we've heard was a lot of
like background noises
and like ambient noises
and Mikasa yelling Eren
from a long way away.
- Okay, that could mean anything (laughs)
- Was could mean anything, I mean like,
I'm obviously not doing the audio justice,
but sound it epic.
- Can we get a one-to-one
reenact (mumbles)
- It was just like
(cheering)
That's all the well.
(Garnt meows)
- Just were screaming in there.
(laughing)
- Yeah, but I mean,
I'm obviously not doing the audit just as
but it sounded like when
I just like close my eyes
and heard that I was like,
wow I've never been more
excited for anime in my life.
- It's good to know that the anime
and the Manga will end
with Mikasa screaming Eren
and she has that.
- Technically a spoiler.
- She has done for the
entire fucking series.
(laughing)
- I mean with the track
record the Attack on Titan
has right now.
I mean it's, every episode you could argue
has been really good, right?
I mean this story has just been,
there's no faults in
the story so far, right.
It holding up pretty well.
- Yeah, I say it had been
building on his story.
- Right really well
- Really, really well.
- Like what if this, if
they nail this ending,
what like category is this end-of-life?
- Master piece.
- What would you put it
as like in like anime
in the same category then if
it killed this last season?
- My fucking God!
- Like 'cause couldn't
even be in its own thing
where like no anime is like as good?
- I would say
- It's hot.
- That's not to say, that's
a big statement right there.
- But I mean, I'm just
trying to think how many,
how many anime series have there been
where it's stretched out for,
I mean
- Over 50 episodes
- Over 50 episodes, like
let's say four or five seasons
and has like killed at this hard.
- Yeah I would say it
be similar to something
like Fullmetal Alchemist, Hunter Hunter.
Although I'd say it's, I haven't
seen Fullmetal Alchemist.
I get that's.
(laughing)
(Joey screaming)
My fan base, my fan base knows this.
This is a big fucking Meme
but Fullmetal Alchemist is that one anime
that I haven't seen.
We all have that one anime.
- I guess when I think about you know,
Hunter Hunter for it's,
I mean, it hasn't ended though,
which is probably the one
where you couldn't argue
it's in the same class
but I guess from a Locus
Brotherhood, maybe you could.
- Yeah, because you never
know like Hunter Hunter
might, I'm hoping God, but you never know
but Hunter Hunter, might
end up like Yu Yu Hakusho.
- I think that's the problem
that I think everyone's kind of beginning
to accept that slowly
because the world is just especially now
with the dark continent stuff,
which, you know it's a lot
of stuff in Hunter Hunter
but it's looking like it's
even more ambitious than before
and he's not releasing
chapters at a very slow, right.
- It's gonna take a whole
lifetime to catch up
but going back to Attack on Titan,
I think I called it like,
if it's even if it was of the quality
of season three part two
ended in that quality,
it would be a modern classic.
- Oh, for sure?
- Yeah, if it's even better than that,
I have no fucking clue
but that makes me so excited.
- So we might be getting the...
- The fact that there's
a possibility of that.
- Yeah.
- It's just nuts.
- I think the last time I
was possibly that excited
for like a followup was
One-Punch Man season two.
- We all know how that.
- I'm like it wasn't okay I
rewatched a few clips recently
of One-Punch Man season two.
I know like it wasn't that bad.
I think it's just,
we set our expectations
disgusting we have.
- It wasn't bad.
It was painfully mediocre.
- It's like Seven Deadly Sins season one.
And then it like.
So what I'm hoping, what I'm hoping is
the next season, assuming
we get another one
of One-Punch Man is it
doesn't go to sleep.
(laughing loudly)
- Oh my God.
That shit is still
like, I haven't seen any
of Seven Deadly Sins.
I don't know anything about it.
Never had the manga and
never watched the anime,
but not gonna lie,
there's a part of me when I
saw footage of season three.
I was like, I kind of wanna watch this now
Just to see it devolve
into this current state.
- Like I remember because the
fight that they fucked up,
was one of the most collective sites.
- In the manga, right the survival.
- Yeah he was one of the most hyped fights
And then they fought it up
so much that fan animation
of that fight that was released before,
looked better than the official fights.
- Because when I found out about
that scene is someone put it up on Twitter
and had to preface it by saying,
no this is not a fun animation.
This is the official episode.
Because everybody in that tweet was like,
is this fun made?
This has to be fun made
This is like some guy
who like just learn how
to use flash like a week ago.
- Just, you know what
sticks out in my mind
that kick, the kick.
(laughing)
When that give first came
out and I saw the kick
which you probably see
him on screen right now.
I lost it.
- Oh my God, I laughed so hard.
- I don't think I'd ever,
like, I've watched all
of Seven Deadly Sins up until that point.
And like, I wasn't like a huge fun,
but we bought every time
a new season was announced
to be of UVA's I'd watched them.
- Yeah.
- I'd never so quickly
lost interest in a series
just from seeing that one screenshot.
Melitis like getting the bed.
I was like, what did they do to him?
What did they do to him?
(laughing)
We've never seen anything like
is that happen anime before
like where a season is like
so drastically like
changed studios and lost.
- I'm sure like if you take.
- I know there have been,
and I know I'm going to kill myself
for not remembering like what this is
but there's been so many times that's.
- That drastic though.
- Yeah.
- It has been a few months
- May be because the difference
was is when it happened back
then is that there wasn't Twitter.
And when it happens now or
you know, when it happens now.
- Yeah exactly,
there was just like a
bunch of light we'll talk,
gathering, being linked, (mumbles)
- Like the only thing I
can think of right now,
is like off the top of my head is Bizarre.
Which I mean, it's changed studio
but it was technically a continuation.
- Okay, what's worse than Bizarre
The second adaptation of Bizarre
or the Seven Deadly Sins the new seasons.
- Bizarre.
- Really.
- It might say Bizarre, yeah.
- Okay.
- Because I mean, like, you know,
I'm seeing that from like
a hardcore Bizarre fan.
- I haven't heard the Mangas so.
- Yeah so if he goes,
if you've read the manga
and I'm sure everybody
who's read the Manga can agree with this
but I have never wanted
to like cry from sadness.
(laughing)
I'm like, how could they
do my boy guards like that?
And I'm like, yeah, this is.
Because the Bizarre
adaptation was just a failure
on pretty much
- Every level
- Every level from like the animation
which everyone likes to point out.
But like the composition,
the sound design.
I mean, if you've heard,
if you heard that like
(body parts breaking)
Like sound, it's just,
what how did you get this?
Who did you hire to do the sound artists?
- Fucking came up with that sound
- Like, how did you see
this big fucking iron sword?
And just like,
- Let's pull it out the Cal Bell.
(laughing)
- Just do Jojo
Make everything a gunshot.
- I mean gun would been
even better honestly.
- Can I talk about Jojo sound design?
I love Jojo sound design so much
because sound design is something
that people don't normally talk about.
And you don't, you don't really,
you don't really hear people
- It's like voice (mumbles) right.
When it's done well, you don't notice.
- Yeah, so with Jojo sound design,
it's one of the few shows where
if you hear like a sound,
- You know is from Jojo.
- You know the exact stance
and you know, like sometimes
it's the exact episode
and the exact fights
because they're that recognized when
that they're like not generic at all.
And I fucking love Jojo sound design
because the reason why I
think the anime is as good
as it is, one of the reasons is
that the sound design is so good.
Like, have you guys seen the
I assume you guys have seen the Jojo OPs
where they add the sound effects.
- And it's so much better, isn't it?
- So cool.
I don't know why they didn't do that
for the Eren versions.
- I mean, it's not really
what you see in an OPs.
- It is pretty unconventional
- But I mean, there's so many sounds
that you could say, like
I call it, like, when
you hear that gunshot
for the punch, you know
what the Jojo punch.
- Yeah, yeah.
And it makes it sound so meaty.
It's great.
- Oh, I love that
- That's the punching sound
is like every time, you know like there's
like a mood or like or
an oral or on like, the,
it is almost like gun like, isn't it
- I'm pretty sure it's like gunshot here.
It's a gunshot.
And then obviously
there's a Waldo timestamp.
(light strikes)
Which I feel like has almost
become the universal sound
of stopping time.
- Yeah, exactly.
(laughing)
And then there's also the you know, I mean
if you talk about music alone, my God,
of the new season absolutely killed it.
- Oh my God, yeah.
- It's like, I think super,
a part of Giorno said this
in his review of Golden Wind
and I feel the same way.
Like this is Golden Wind
was the first adaptation
of a Jojo where I think
the anime is better
because you lose so much
when you take away that sound right
and especially the music.
When you hear that Giorno's Theme come on.
- Giorno's Theme is one of the few tracks
in anime that has been means to death.
- Yeah it is Al megalomania.
- And I have not gotten bored of it all
- Every like every version of heard
of Giorno's Theme have the equally,
just be like yes.
(laughing)
It's so like a piano
version, middle version,
I don't care.
It's always been so good.
- Yeah go on so on.
- When we can go back to the gym,
some of the best music to put
when you're working out is Jojo's.
It works so well.
And I know it should work well,
but man when that piano hits,
you're doing an extra rep,
no matter how tired you are,
you're doing that extra rep.
- Yeah it's so good.
- It's almost too hype sometimes
you are like a shit I got
to keep doing this rapper.
I'm dying right now.
I don't know where my boy, Jojo down.
- Speaking of anime adaptations though,
there is one topic I would like to cover
because it is quite timely.
But just yesterday I
actually recording over
as of us recording this episode,
I found or I I guess AKI found
that somebody is adapting,
Killing Stalking.
- You mean it's not an official
- This needs the biggest
quote marks ever adapting
- "Adapting" Killing Stalking "Anime."
- You there is no an
official animate adaptation
like everyone on Twitter thinks it is.
- Okay.
- It was like pop most
the original Twitter post
that blew this up
said an official adaptation.
And then in the reply to that tweet,
they doubled down saying it.
"Yeah, it was all official."
But the thing that caught
my eye is the picture
that everyone was re-tweeting right.
Three pictures of this tweet.
One of them, it was like chAosOPUS STUDIO.
The fuck it's a chAosOPUS STUDIO
- Yeah so like, 'cause AKI
found that on a timeline
and was like Holy shit they're making us
Killing Stalking anime adaptation.
I'm like, really let me see.
And I saw the pictures
on like the first two
and it was like coming soon, 2020.
I was like, oh shit okay.
And then I looked at the last one
and it was like chAosOPUS STUDIO?
I'm like,
- Yeah, yeah right.
- Who? (laughing)
What is the Studio?
I legitimately had to look
it up on Wikipedia being like
maybe it's just one of them.
'Cause you know, recently there've been
so many fucking Japanese
anime studio guys come out
with like ridiculous names.
I'm like, probably it's just one of those.
- Exactly.
- I looked it up and I'm like,
Nope, it's literally just one dude.
(laughs)
It's a one dude.
- I feel bad for whoever's making this
'cause like my God they wanna hype,
they just got thrusted on them.
And everyone's assuming
this is like legit.
- I mean, how did the hype just happen?
Did they just
- There is literally just the tweet.
- Just the tweet.
- Yeah, the original Twitter I think
has all of us recording,
I think it has like 40,000
likes and like 20,000 retweets
or something that.
- Wow.
- Because Killing Stalking
fans are flawless.
They are ruthlessly dedicated.
- And then I saw, the thing
was this one in the lower
in the replies to that
people weren't questioning
whether like it was legit.
People were just questioning.
Should it get an adaptation?
And that was the main argument.
I think that's why it was
getting so many reasons.
- Should you guys think he
should get an adaptation?
I mean, let me change the question.
Have you guys read it?
- I've read the first like story.
What is it like it came out
and like stories, right?
- It's like seasons.
- Yeah I watched, I read the first season
and I quite liked it
and you know, it's a lot
but I feel like from
what I've heard as well
that handles it quite
well towards the end.
- Yeah I did a video on it.
I actually looked back
on when I did my video
of it was four years ago.
- Holy shit.
Was it that long ago?
- Yeah
- I remember you released
that like yesterday
- I thought was like maybe
like a year or two ago
- Yeah
- Was four years ago.
And that's because I only
reviewed the first season
because I think the series ended
like I think it was like last year.
- Yeah.
- Yeah
- But it was like a huge gap right.
So I've only really seen or read
like the first half of it.
And it was, you know,
it was marketed as like,
it's a really hard call,
like gruesome yellowish.
So you know, all these
fan girls getting on it.
And I was like, okay,
I mean, I don't know if
I'm gonna enjoy it as much
because I'm not exactly
the target demographic
but I'll give it a go.
And it was like a genuinely good story.
Like yeah it had yellow elements in it,
but you know, I'm an
adult, I can handle that.
So other than, if you take
away the yellow elements,
it's just a really, really
good horror mystery.
But when I sold that they
were gonna make a quote
"anime adaptation for it."
I was like, I don't know
because immediately what I
thought of is all of these
other like over-sexualized series getting
anime adaptations recently
- Cause as someone who hasn't read,
it seems like it's a very sexual story
that would have to be heavily sensitive.
- It is hardcore
- Is one of, I think it
will say it has such a
like it's divided a lot of community.
'Cause I think a lot of
people really sexualize it
when it's just a really fucked up dynamic
and a lot of, I mean a
lot of really deep shit of
like possessiveness and all that.
But if you've thinking about reading it,
it's a lot like it's
- Going into with caution definitely.
- Definitely be over the age of 18.
- We have to legally say that.
(laughing loudly)
- I think you should read it
but then also like I can
totally recommend you not
to read it like it's your
life would be totally fine
if you don't read it.
- May be I'll watch the anime instead
in my opinion they're.
- Talking about the anime,
like I said, I feel bad for this person.
'Cause a lot of people are
putting a lot of hype on it.
But also what I saw, it's a one man job
like this guy's doing everything.
And I don't know if it's a guy or a girl
but they seem to be in charge of,
they seem to be 3D modelers.
I think that's what that trade is.
And I saw the voice acting Casting Call
and as someone who's, you know,
done a lot of voice acting Casting Calls,
I've made my own, I've worked with a lot
of professional ones
like it is not normal.
I had to say,
I don't wanna be mean to them
'cause I don't think that
like that experience.
And I think other voice actors
are helping them with it.
But first of all, normally you don't name
who's gotten what role publicly.
Right so on the Casting Call Document
which I think we've maybe
show on screen for a second.
It says like one person who has the role
and it's showing publicly,
that's not normally the case.
Normally it's just here with the lines,
auditioned for it.
And the way it's laid out is really old.
And it's just over, I mean, over Twitter,
isn't that weird
but there's no mention of pay or anything.
Like I guess, I mean,
it is a fan made project
but normally, still you
say if it's paid or not.
- Yeah.
- You normally say how, you know,
how many lines they're gonna be.
It just, I don't know.
It looks like it belongs
on like Casting Call Club
which is an amateur voice hunting website.
- Yeah.
- Which makes me uneasy because
if it is gonna be a USB
microphone kind of deal,
it's not can sound good
'cause there was no,
here's the minimum the requirements
for you to sanitary
room, there was nothing.
It was just, if you wanna audition.
And I saw the replies to this thread
and it was like all
13-year old sounding girls auditioning.
(laughing)
- Yeah but that's because
the main like readership all
of Killing Stalking our 13 year old girls,
even though it shouldn't be
from purely based on context,
it should not be.
- It's just worrying with
these kinds of things as well
'cause normally like when
I've done plus 18 projects,
I normally ask for proof of ID
when they if I cast someone
like they need to show me their ID
and this should definitely
be one of those situations
where I like those
precautions should be taken
even if it's fan made right.
Like, yeah, not good look for you
if you're getting 13-old girls to voice
in your thing about like,
you know some pretty fun shit.
- I mean it's still very early days,
I mean from what it sounds like,
it's sounds like a situation where someone
just
- way too much press.
- Got way too much press, way too quickly
because I have no doubt
that they probably have
no fucking experience.
- Because I saw it on the Twitter actually
just this morning.
Yeah they tweeted out
being like, oh my God
after someone retweeted my thing,
I've gained like 10,000 Twitter
followers in like overnight.
And like, you know, this
person obviously like came
from like pretty much
close to zero followers.
So for them that's a lot.
- Yeah.
- That's a lot of like
pressure just immediately built
up on them because you're going after such
like, I don't want to say iconic
but like a very, like very,
very dedicated series.
- I think it's not just that as well.
Cause I think what
really built up the hype
as well as we're in like
this environment now
where Webtoons animated.
- They could be.
- Are being major so you wouldn't be,
it wouldn't have been surprising
to say Killing Stalking
is getting an anime
as opposed to like last
year even two years ago
where, you know we didn't
have any precedents for that
but now we've Tower of God airing
and a God of High School
and Noblesse all getting anime.
It's like maybe we're in a new era
where people are expecting
that their favorite Webtoons
or their favorite webcomics
for whatever country could
get anime adaptations.
- Yeah sure, sure.
- I mean to be fired, I
wouldn't be against the idea
of actually getting an
official adaptation.
- Or Killing Stalking?
- Yeah I think it could
be definitely make waves.
- I mean it would make
sense considering that
recently there's been
like a big trend of like,
as I said earlier, like
over-sexualized series
like we've got a Shu Matson airing getting
- Yeah my fucking God,
how they gonna handle it?
- How are they gonna handle that?
Because there is legitimately a sex scene
every three pages.
Like I'm not even kidding.
- So I don't know anything
about this monograph.
So wait, what is it called?
- It's called Shu Matson Harold.
- Or Wild Hentai
- And basically the overall
plum oversimplifying this
but basically.
- It's a handclap flawed.
- Humanity has gone to shit,
where there was a disease
that is killing all males.
It's already affecting males.
So basically now
- You can tell
(laughing)
- It's a hentai plot.
It's a hentai plot.
So basically males now are becoming
like a commodity they're
basically being treated
like males that have like
survived this disease.
- Yeah.
- Basically like treated
as like national defenses.
- Let me just wait, first
of all the difference
between this hentai, right?
Is that if it was a hentai,
it'd be an ugly bastard.
- Yeah.
- It's like a handsome young guy.
- It's like several handsome young guys.
- Okay that's how it happened.
It's an ugly bastard.
It's a hentai (Garnt laughs)
- But like the dynamic it could see,
this is where a difference from a hentai
though is that our main
character has like this girl
that he's been thinking
about his whole life.
And basically like, doesn't
wanna just go around
and like just scrap their
sex everyone in order
to save him he'd rather
keep his like purity
for the goal that he
needs to be thinking of.
- So it's about waiting
for the right person.
- It's basically blue balls, the manga.
Because everyone else all five other guys
having a fucking great time.
They're fucking different
chicks every day.
- They're pretty much,
they're pretty much like
what hentai of protagonist
should be
- I'm not being sold on this,
but saying that I wasn't sold
to Interspecies Reviewers
until I watched it.
This is pretty funny.
- It's not gonna be as good.
- Oh no.
- Interspecies Reviewers
is like a really weird case
because it was something
that was definitely,
definitely itchy in the manga,
in the manga in the anime.
They just made it porn.
But I still like, I still, I don't know
Interspecies Reviewers to me is that line
between hentai and (mumbles)
because you don't watch
Interspecies Reviewers
to jack off right.
But it's undeniable
that there is just a
straight up sex scene in it.
- Which is really interesting though
because the one sex scene
that everyone was raving
on about in the anime, I
think it was episode four,
- Three
Episode three was never in the Manga.
- No, it wasn't.
- It was implied all sex
scenes of the series is implied
in the Manga.
But in the anime that
was just like fucking
let's just show it, like.
- Put things into perspective.
You didn't even see nipple in the Manga.
That was like,
- That's a lie.
- You did it.
- Yeah, you didn't see nipple.
I know I own all the volumes.
(laughing)
- You seen this man's Twitter.
He knows a nipple when he sees.
- I all know the volumes
And I've enjoyed every single one.
- Can we talk about your Twitter in a bit?
Can we please talk legit?
Because it would make me play
- By the way follow me on
Twitter guys that the anime
with a wrong clip.
(laughing)
- Can you please explain your Twitter?
- What's meanings explain my Twitter.
- First of all, whenever
I go on Twitter, right?
I don't follow Hentai artists on Twitter
because I don't need to
because this man's got me COVID
because I actually know on Twitter.
When you, like a picture,
there's a good chance
for some reason, especially
Joey's specifically
it comes on my Twitter and I must get
at least every time I open
Twitter, six or seven, like
either like follow on sex
things or like very, very loose.
It's always Joey.
It's like, I'm like I don't follow porn
like Joey Bissinger and it's like
how does she get to this point?
- Okay here's what I
don't understand, right?
Like how many people do
you follow on Twitter?
Like on average
- I think I have 600 something.
- Okay 600
- Above them I mean
- Okay, right you both
follow about over 500 people.
- Yeah.
- And like this isn't just YouTube
like I've had this from
like mutual friends of mine.
- Everyone says, it's you.
- How is it that my likes end
up on everybody's timeline?
Like, am I only like Twitter preferred?
- I have no fucking clue, but it is,
I would say 70 to 80%
of the time I see Ludes
on my timeline, it is you.
It is trade-off
- First of all, you're welcome.
(laughing)
- Okay 'cause this thing
used to be the case.
And like, I swear, you were
way more timid about it.
How did, 'cause I'm scared of doing that.
I don't know 'cause I
mean, I shouldn't really,
'cause there basically
half naked into my videos,
but I don't know I was getting,
I was just worried about
like, she just having porn
on my thing, but now I guess
I can get away with it.
How did you go from not sharing porn
to basically just
- To being the Hentai.
- I've always shared it, that's the thing.
- Have you?
I swear you didn't.
- I mean maybe not only.
- No, no, no
- This one now you're seeking.
- I think it was just Twitter
changing the like button
to be basically the retweet
- That's a pretty much.
That's exactly what it is.
Because for the entirety
that I've been on Twitter
I've liked hentai
because I followed hentai
like people like hentai out side
like Titan I've discovered,
but I've never retweeted it
because of this exact reason.
I don't want other people's timelines
to be filled with hentai.
But Twitter was just like,
hey, let's just like,
make the like button, like
a better retweet button.
- I gonna ask how much
of your feed is Just had?
- That's why I asked, I
asked to see his phone.
- Do you wanna see it now?
It wasn't that bad when I first saw it,.
- I mean, the thing is I don't follow
that many hentai artists.
I know that's hard to believe,
but I genuinely don't,
the thing is I follow a hentai artists
that love retweeting other hentai artists.
And that's where I find all the people.
Okay, here.
- Scroll, scroll through it.
- You want scroll down my Twitter.
- Let's see.
- Let's see how many come up?
- There one, one and three.
- Can you also like
everyone that opinions.
(laughing)
- You go to his likes from when this is
- Go to my likes, go to my likes.
- Hope that's another one?
- That's two in a row.
- Oh, wait that's a Jimmy Neutron there.
That's my mentor.
(laughing)
- Oh my phone.
Okay, let me, while they're
looking through the Twitter,
let me defend myself real quick, okay.
The reason why I like it's
because at the end of the day,
these are just drawings, right?
There's a difference between
liking like actual human porn
versus just a picture.
- This man is about to go the hentai.
(laughs)
- I am genuinely one of those people
who looks at hentai as odd.
- I totally agree with you.
(Conner laughs)
Shut up, fuck.
- I'm sorry.
- I'm talking on behalf
of every hentai lover
watching this episode,
including you
- I love hentai.
I just I don't know if I
look at it and be unlike,
just crack open a beer and just enjoy.
- The boy, no, no, no.
I've gotten to that point, right?
I've gotten to the point
of you seeing fucking room,
you see my fucking office,
which is just like full
of like anime thighs
and stuff like that.
Because it's gotten to the point
where sometimes you just see this
like drawing of a girl
or a thigh or something.
And I just don't even get horny anymore.
I'm just like, I'm fucking impressed
at how good they make.
- That was me when I saw them (mumbles)
in Seven Deadly Sins.(Garnt laughs)
- Because they're genuinely
like some hentai artists
that I've seen.
And I know of where I'm just like,
if you made an all ages manga,
you would sell like crazy.
- Oh no and people have.
- And people have like
look at like (mumbles)
who made fucking easy
on Nathan Novato song.
- Yeah, yeah I love that.
(laughing)
- I know, you know put up a picture of it.
But okay everyone has seen
this chick before, all right.
Nano she was originally
like a hardcore lowly hentai artist.
And he made a really
fucking six for all ages,
comedy Manga which is hilarious.
- Yeah.
- And like and even if
they don't make all,
they just stuff, look
at artists like Nambata
who is like genuinely an amazing artist.
And that's what I will
like, because you know,
we've gotten to this point
where hentai has just become
like ha ha anime, boobs,
hilarious and horny on me.
Like it's all just
become like a joke thing.
I don't want that anymore.
- I don't want that.
- I'm sick of those jokes.
- I want to save this
topic because I want.
I want this to be a whole episode.
- I'm ready.
I want to dedicate a whole episode.
I have too many things to say
about hentai artists that I can't fit all
like five minutes.
- Smashed like on this episode,
if you want hentai episode
because we're gonna do it either way.
- We're gonna do it any way.
- To give this guy is
like three sips of beer
and they start talking about hentai.
- I shouldn't had a strong
(laughing)
This is strong.
- I just, I don't know
like when I watch hentai,
it's like it's for a service, you know?
I guess I do it to do,
I do the deed, right?
Like I don't sit there and
like swallow my wine glass
and things.
- Am I weird?
Am I okay?
I wanna know.
- Yeah this is probably the answer to
- Am I weird to be like sometimes I kinda
just wanna watch Hentai just doing this.
- Yes that's totally.
- (laughs) That's fucking weird.
Come on he's probably going
through that phase right now.
- No, no I don't, hentai to
me hasn't got to that point.
The Doujinshi and manga.
Has definitely go into that
- Let's see if this (mumbles).
- There is no part of me
in a porn while I like,
I watch a porn and I don't
immediately skip two minutes then.
- You are the degenerates
here, motherfucking.
- I bought a lot Doujinshi
from my artists I like,
I don't think I've actually read
like physical copies of and
like hijacked off to it.
I know that's TMI I'm sorry,
- I will recommend you some share.
- Okay.
- I do.
- I'll come on and see in Twitter likes
and in like four episodes.
I'll come back on and be like
totally agree with everything.
Everything these guys say.
I don't know I just.
- Also like, you'll like
progression from like,
what the fuck to like, you know what?
I love this artist.
- Because it's, if you've
read enough Doujinshi
and you've, if you've
read enough like H manga,
there are so many the Doujinshi
that just have really, really good plots.
- I agree.
- It's this.
- (mumbles) sphere
Yeah I do agree.
I must say.
(laughing)
- It's gotten to this
point where sometimes you
just want the series to
be adapted into hentai
I just so you can see an animated
and sometimes you read the series
that just do something new with porn
or hentai that you just
have never seen before.
And you're like, wow, this
is like awakening something
in me right now.
This is amazing.
(laughing)
- Seriously.
- I've never heard someone describe,
I've watched hentai and
awakened something in him.
- How Levi you know.
- There was some Doujinshi (mumbles)
like at first I was like,
okay, I dig this art.
And then I see like the ECI scenes
and I'm like, okay, I'm digging this.
Like, you know me, I have
like a quarter child.
But then as the story continues,
I'm like, you know what?
Fuck the HTC.
- (mumbles) of the
podcast to the wrong boys.
- That question to you a
question to all of you watching.
Why do you think thigh highs are sexy?
And if the answer isn't anime
and anime awakened your love
for fire highs, you're fucking.
- No I did I mean,
- Because let's be real Japanese
girls don't have thighs.
- Yeah, that's true.
- Yeah, so like, if you just think,
if you fire thighs is
like entry level right
in the world of the Doujinshi and H manga
that's like some normie shit man.
(laughing loudly)
They've gotten to that
point with enormous fuck.
- Maybe in future, we
can return to this topic
when I've you know done my research.
- Will come back.
We're gonna come back to it,
don't worry, don't worry.
- So we're getting ahead
of ourselves right now.
Okay like this,
- That's an understatement.
- This was meant to be
an introductory episode
when we introduced whatever,
well we're gonna be doing.
- If don't like these topics, I'm sorry.
(laughing)
- Always be hentai by the way.
Can I just preface that?
I just, but I think, I mean,
the main reason we started this as well,
because we always hang out together.
Like it's not one of those things
like some YouTube is hangout.
They make videos.
It seems like they're friendships great,
we all actually hang out
together all the fucking time.
And we always talk for like two hours
- What we're looking at it's essentially
what we do on a daily.
- Yeah like, we easily have conversations
where we just talk for like three hours
about manga an anime.
- Not even about manga anime
I remember the last time
we were at your house
and we talked about like,
what was the best book you joined?
(laughing) Do you remember that.
We like legitimately like hardcore arguing
about like easy in-and-out
overrated or not for like
- It's not by the way.
- It is.
- Okay we're not gonna get into that.
But I suppose, I guess that's,
we're gonna be talking about like anything
and it's gonna evolve over the time.
I mean the core of this anime and manga
- I mean, I have a lot of
things about anime and manga
that I wanna talk about,
but I also want to talk
about the culture, the community, hentai,
more hentai I guess.
- Yeah and I mean,
- I'm for this.
- Also like just general
'cause we're YouTubers is we
wanna talk about sometimes
if there's YouTube drama that we feel
like we can probably add
something to it like of course.
- You know, sometimes if there's just
like standard banter of just like,
whatever the fuck then, will talk.
- And if any of our
mutuals are ever in Japan,
like if you wanna talk anime
manga with us hit us up.
- Yeah, absolutely.
And not even just our
mutuals, like if you're just
if you don't wanna like come onto the show
and like talk, first of all
you gotta come on to the show,
physically sit right here next to me
and talk about it.
- Because we wanna ideally this
will be a full person podcast.
And hopefully, I mean
I'd be really interested
in to bring YouTube is on who,
don't really get to talk about anime.
- Yeah
- Absolutely.
- And I just hear that side.
- Yeah I mean if there were
any YouTube is watching
this video or you know,
the Twitter or whatever,
then I guess let us know
if you'd like to come onto the podcast.
'Cause we will happily welcome come on.
- Because it's surprising
I've met so many YouTubers
who have nothing to do
with anime or anything.
- Who watch anime.
- Who watch anime
and just really wanna talk
about anime to somewhere.
And I think it's pretty awesome
because I remember anime was nowhere
near this popular before.
And I remember the feeling
of being the only anime fan
and have having nothing.
I have no one to talk about.
- I mean I think that's why
I started my YouTube channel.
But that was like my
reasoning is that I had no one
to talk to this about.
- Let's just say like kids
today, have it fucking easy.
If you're an anime fan like
today, you know, High School,
you have it so much
easier than any of busted.
- My God, I wish I'm so jealous
because I wish I could have just talked
to my fucking friends
about Narrow Toe or Bleach
or One Piece or something.
- I had to convince my
friends to get into anime
in order for them in order
to find someone about anime.
- See, this is like another thing that I,
when I talked to Americans,
they don't have this problem,
at least in my age group.
(mumbles)
It's like we had Americans
had a good but British people
and I think probably Australian people are
more closer to British like
fucking ruthless school.
Oh yeah.
- No, definitely.
- And I remember I got shiffer
gaming too much at school.
So am I other fuck my gonna.
- I mean at that.
- I go shiffer gaming too much in school.
So am I gonna sit there
and be like, all right.
So call of duty, that thing that you play
but give me shit for,
how about you check out
these animated, he's right.
Like how do I,
I built up years getting to
like a medium level of like
in between a level of popularity.
I was never popular, but I
got out of the bullying zone
if you will.
Didn't wanna go back to that.
- It's really crazy just how like,
I don't want to say mainstream animes.
- It's not mainstream.
- It's not mainstream at all,
but like I guess just
how much more accepted it's
become as a subculture.
- It's get enough.
- It's definitely,
definitely is because I feel
like anime works so
well with Meme culture.
- Oh my,
- You know what I mean?
An anime in a sense is Meme culture
in a lot of ways, I mean
- Flying a room when you
mentioned Meme culture and anime
(laughing)
You all know what we're talking about.
- But I feel like because of that,
it's a lot more people know what anime is
or at least have seen
a Meme or a screenshot
or a gift of probably Jojo.
- This is usually where they start.
- That's usually will happen.
- And as it should be,
- It's the only enemy that matters.
- And then people would just
recognize that a lot more.
Cause I remember when I was growing up,
people didn't even know what anime was,
the word anime they're
like, what the fuck is this?
That's some cartoon porn,
you know what I mean?
- Yeah, absolutely.
- It's weird 'cause I
think one of the biggest
like double-edged swords to anime
has been Netflix,
like in the sense that like
it's got a lot of people
into anime.
- Yeah
- But then when you get really into anime,
it becomes like the fucking (mumbles).
- I mean are we definitely
gonna talk about light,
- True that more future.
But I think Netflix is also helped a lot
'cause I mean, they've been pushing
like I remember like when
they started getting anime
like Death and it would not
get off my fucking recommended
on Netflix
- Really?
- Yeah, yeah.
And like Fullmetal lockers brother
had I think they have that.
I think they have all the classics
which is pretty impressive.
- Yeah.
- I mean they have all the
entry level most for me to
- Need to watch.
Now they have Evangelion as well.
- Yeah exactly
- Which is
- Crazy they call that
- That's just, I can't
imagine how much money Netflix
through no, be like, hey,
can we grab your series
that has been pretty much out of print
for like 20 plus years.
- I wanna hear the story
about how they got that
because people have tried for decades,
literally decades to
get the often ADV died
to get the licensing over to the West.
So there must be.
- I remember when I
- Lots and lots of money.
- I wrote whatever that use it badly.
I actually couldn't believe it.
I was like, this is like one
of the biggest achievements
because it is like, like, you know,
without you know wrapping
it up in a package nicely
like Evangelion is one of the
biggest anime like ever made
and like I know we all know
I know is like hardcore
when it comes to protecting it's IP.
- Oh my God!
- Cause I remember for the
longest time Hollywood wanted
to make that Evangelion adaptation
and unknown was just like, fuck off fame.
- Like he did a solid, he does this.
- There are so many
live action adaptations
being made right now.
I couldn't keep track of them all.
I remember when there was just one
and everyone would just
wait a shit on that one.
But I think there's like
over 10 adaptations being made right now.
- We need to do an episode
or we do like a Tier List
of the worst Netflix adaptations
- We need to do a Tier
List of the fly back.
- Oh God yeah.
- So anyways guys look
forward to all of that stuff.
- This was just a taster.
We didn't really plan much
of what we were gonna say.
- As you can see, we're
just talking out of our.
- We were just talking about
there wasn't a topic planned
and we just kind of evolved (laughs)
- The only talk we talked
about was Killing Stalking,
which last five minutes.
(laughing)
- There we a lot more structure in future
when we get a bit more used to it as well.
Let me have more topics to talk about
but because right now,
we'll do wanna cover.
I think it would make it
really interesting video
you hear our opinions pretty early
on about things that are
like evolving situations.
- And also, if you wanna hear anything
or if you wanna request anything
that you want to hear us talk about,
you can tweet at us
- @TrashTastePod.
Go onto Twitter and give
us your suggestions.
If you guys would also like to ask
like any questions like Q
and A and stuff like that
- We'll probably have a Q and A section
- And then we'll probably
grab some questions
over Twitter as well.
Basically, if you like to
interact with us in any way
for future episodes, then
definitely follow us on Twitter.
- Yeah
- And also, yeah, just subscribe.(laughs)
I don't wanna be that guy to be like,
subscribe, like video.
(mumbling)
But if you do, then that
would greatly help us out
and be greatly appreciate it.
- As you can see where it's still in like,
I'd say like Beta,
the Beta Stage of this podcast.
- Yeah.
We're gonna be filling up the background
and everything done.
- I'm sorry about that.
If you found this episode and enjoyed it
before we've even pushed it on
our main channel, thank you.
That's pretty
- Thank you
rarely appreciate the guys.
- Yeah I think that's a good
place to end it for now.
- Yeah we're gonna be
uploading at least one a week
and we have a highlight
channel as well coming out.
So yeah, you can expect at
least one of this week .
- Yeah, but look forward to that guys.
Thanks for watching.
I've been Joey.
- I've been Garnt.
- Conner or CDawg Virginia.
- Or Gigguk.
Gigg UK.
- Anime woman
(laughing)
And we appreciate you guys
for sticking around this first episode
and we hope to see you
guys in the next one.
All right.
- All right
Nice, bye bye.
- Bye.